we've got new details breaking overnight
though about the rest of a man on a
weapons charge
outside vice president kamala harris's
official residence
please say that he came to washington
and he was heavily armed
jeff pigues joins us now with more on
this story so jeff what do we know about
him and what do we know about his arrest
well gail the man charged his
31-year-old paul murray of san antonio
texas d.c police arrested him
near the naval observatory in the early
afternoon
images taken from a video at the scene
show the confrontation with authorities
d.c police said that officers recovered
a rifle and ammunition from
murray's car which was parked in a
garage a police report obtained by cbs
news says
that he was in possession of an ar-15
semi-automatic rifle 113 rounds of
unregistered ammunition and five
30-round magazines
an intelligence bulletin from texas
described murray as someone experiencing
paranoid delusions including one that
the military and government were after
him
he texted his mother yesterday morning
that he would be
in d.c now the vice president has not
moved into the naval observatory just
yet so she was not there
but of course this incident is certainly
alarming at a time of heightened
security around here
because of the capital attack anthony
alarming to say the least jeff thank you